um well your sister catherine i've had  her on the show before i love her  she's great super sweet but she's about  to come on again so  is there something i should ask her uh  i'm sure you guys are gonna talk about  uh being a mom or something she just had  she just had a baby like  mom stuff mom stuff you're really  interested in talking about too about  diaper changing i was just about to ask  you some more questions too  she's yet to hit me with a diaper change  and thank god because that's not  happening  oh i didn't change no baby's diaper  until it was mine  yep i'm still here just waiting for you  to subscribe  if you don't i'll be trapped in this box  forever